i'll play this person rated 22.69
okay i'm gonna mix up the openings um
ah it's a london okay well i'll play
yeah i'll play what i like usually like
to play against the london is
early c5 i'm gonna try and do the same
sort of strategy i just showed
but with a black side there are cases
where
this doesn't quite work the way you
wanted to but
this is a case where a queen b6 is gonna
lead to a comfortable position okay so
queen b3 was the main move this is
playable
hey bossman hey boss man
thank you urban peruser and naked yeti
any tips on getting past 1900 elo
been stuck at this level for a while
that's typical
the higher you climb the harder it is to
i guess climb further so it's important
to be patient
don't be too fixated on reading can i
play this move
takes take some knights a bit misplaced
um i should have played
i should have played um h6 before e6 but
oh what to do maybe i'll play bishop e4
i'll see what it wants to do
it's actually common like when you start
reaching higher ratings
is your overall level will improve
before your rating reflects your level
um so it's common to plateau for some
amount of time
and then as long as you're persistent
you keep studying
keep analyzing games that you play
especially your losses
then hopefully at some point you'll have
like a spike
but really it's just about being
persistent enjoying the process
if you're plateaued for a really long
time you might want to mix things up
experiment with maybe new openings new
playing styles
when you make changes sometimes you'll
you'll actually lose your eating but it
will help you
uh it'll help you in the long run but
short term it could
you might see a a decrease but
it's important to have a growth mindset
that you're you're playing to learn
more so than playing to win
uh what to play
i want to keep the rook on h8 enjoy the
file
question is what is a plan maybe asics
some idea just to like very much slow
play like queen h7
b5 and then b4
and white setup like it's
the whole setup is kind of based around
playing e4 but it's hard for white to
play e4 because it weakens d4
so castling okay
it's still kind of hard to attack so i'm
just going to go for this plan okay now
this pawn is a bit more accessible
i mean white's probably preparing e4 hi
eric hi
yeah this is the moment where i'm gonna
have to
focus more on the game than on chat
don't play b5
i'm realizing the king might want to be
on f8
like out of the center but still leaving
the rook on the
half open file
yeah not making any huge commitments
just small
slow improvements
light's kind of doing the same thing
okay now there's some pressure
so i could play this move kind of
relieves all the pressure
i could take taking is interesting
well it takes back this way there's no
more e4
if it takes back this way i have some
like before move
oh there's almost a cool tactic but
never mind
and the tactical idea is knight before
it takes and then queen you're hitting
the pawn and the bishop
i mean maybe a5 first
or b4 first
i'm gonna play a5 so we're playing three
plus one i have a
small increment to work with
this is not rated so i'm not risking
points but
trying to play decent quality chess
let's challenge the night
i still want to use this diagonal
ah i meant to play queen b7 i'm just
losing a pawn now
but maybe white won't take it
that was the whole plan
i don't know if my opponent's watching
like you could easily just
think the pawn is free but yeah the
bishop's now lost
or white's getting mated
that was nice yeah i think white
probably should have played g3 soon
always high quality and i always learn
something
thank you oh thank you
appreciate the kind words
okay let's um let's try and take care of
this
in a clean fashion threatening this now
just avoiding any annoying check i have
a4
wondering how to maybe g5
someone mentioned g5 earlier
[Music]
slowly but surely
never trust an eric rosenthal
sometimes you can i have to watch out my
time
or watch my time
yeah one second increment is not a lot
oh knight e4 such a nice square
okay i just want to play quick moves
game time
attack the pawn win the pawn
win the other pawn
you throw in the check maybe oh i'll
have this move
that was almost kind of painful
okay when another pawn
okay now this pawn has passed
how do i promote in this move
coming
okay this is how i promote
here we go
okay it took some work
that's a fun game
i mean when my point was taking a long
time debating whether to take the pawn
i really didn't think this this move was
coming
i mean queen the whole reason to play
queen a7 was to like fake the mouse slip
like the queen should not has no purpose
on e7
um but that was uh that was interesting
so anyway um yeah this is one of my
favorite lines to play against
the london i'm going to go ahead and
copy this to the study
so this is game one of the stream
um yeah if white plays queen b3 here
this is where i can get a kind of this
nice
space advantage on the queen side and
similar plans apply of
a b5 b4 uh and the main line
main line is something like this where
usually black should play h6 before e6
so okay here white played queen c1 and
then we got
yeah we got a position where i had kind
of had to give away the bishop hair
i probably should have played h6 here
i'm wondering if sometimes an engine can
find cool ideas
so e6 knight i played bishop e4
[Music]
it actually doesn't mind what i played
i gave away the bishop here but white
committed to f3 and i got the h file
so it's something
oh engine wants me to go for this and
then take
yeah because the pawn takes i have this
square maybe
it's playable
anyway uh
yeah i guess the turning point was
bishop takes b5
so that was nice um
one tidbit in the opening at a high
level it's probably better to play
knight d2
because then queen b6 can be met with
queen b3
and if i play c4 then queen c2
[Music]
if the knight was on f3 and this knight
was on b1 i would have bishop f5
but here bishop f5 doesn't work so it's
just a different line